lucy i'm so excited to talk to you now
before we get into the show which i'm
loving by the way
how are you doing during these strange
times like what's keeping you motivated
and happy right now
well thanks for having me on the show
and um
it's so nice to talk to you you're in
canada right
yeah how exciting um i love canadians
okay we love you uh
everything is going actually really well
i'm living with
you know my mom and my son so it's three
generations
under one roof which is uh it's very
it's a very asian community right now um
but we're doing well i mean we're we're
eating in we're going to the farmers
market when we need to to get food and
just trying to be as safe as possible
and you know
uh just keeping our neighbors in mind
essentially yeah
absolutely well that sounds pretty good
actually your situation right now that
sounds awesome
um i'm loving why women kill i mean i
think when it comes to
the first season of a lot of shows it
takes a couple of episodes for
the audience to really connect to the
characters but i was hooked within the
first
five minutes honestly i love it that
much what initially drew you to this
show
um i had a really wonderful conversation
with mark cherry who as you know is a
very colorful
and vibrant and funny human being
and writer and he sort of took me down
the journey of
where simone was going to go emotionally
and the trajectory of their connection
between her and her husband carl who's
the other character in our storyline
who's wonderful played
uh marvelously um
it's just it was a more it wasn't just a
funny kind of
dynamic about you know women in murder
it actually had some kind of a
connection to politics
and uh the aids crisis in the 80s
and i loved that it was not just
one thing so he sort of layered all of
these things on top of each other
which made it special and of course
working with jack davenport was
magnificent yeah you know as you were
saying the cast on this show
is really amazing there's such a strong
element of strong female characters and
and their very personal journeys
throughout season one was that something
that
excited you to explore and to have you
know be a part of when it came to the
show
absolutely i mean i think anything that
is uh
bringing women to the forefront and
making them
[Music]
interesting uh
and very complicated characters uh is
always going to make me
more interested in working on something
and i do think
the the various decades that are
highlighted
show how times have changed but i think
people's reactions
to how uh
you know infidelity when it comes into
your life how do you deal with it
and it's an emotional range uh which
is going to change you know
how you're going to develop as a human
being yeah
you know simone does have quite a tough
storyline as you were saying her
husband is cheating on her with a man or
several men
was exploring that lgbtq plus storyline
and the way in which simone handles it
you know something that really spoke to
you i mean i think that
there's a different levels of shock for
her i think the
the huge impact was that
he was unfaithful to her and that she
found out in a way that was
uh not through him but through somebody
else
um number one and she was throwing this
very lavish party
where she was sort of you know the
center of attention or wanted to be the
center of attention
and then discovered this uh in the midst
of that
and then to find out that it was with a
man and that had been going on
for so how many years who knows uh
it was beyond you know files of
disappointment
it was she was crushed and she had you
know this is her third marriage and she
had married him for love
yeah and so i think the the deception
and the hurt and the pain really
creates this this journey for her where
she makes some really bad choices
nothing lightly um you know there's such
an emotional
storyline when it comes to this
character but also simone has the best
clothing
she has some of the funniest lines how
much fun do you have kind of immersing
yourselves in
in that 80s world i loved it i loved
the costumes i love the the glamour
you know the the big hair the makeup the
the lavish opulent lifestyle yeah
and the sort of the economics of that
time
uh there was a there was a sort of a
blind
way of living you know we never talked
about the environment you never talked
about anything but
you know oneself it was very sort of
egocentric and
i think she starts to open her eyes to a
lot of her world once she realizes
that you know she's been duped
yeah absolutely you just you rock
shoulder pads like no one else it just
looks amazing
um you know diversity is something that
a lot of people are talking about right
now you've been in some of the greatest
you know movies and tv shows
are you noticing change in the industry
is this a time that you're feeling
inspired right now
um i think right now there is a need
for more change and it's not going to
happen overnight
and yeah i think you know
that racial injustice
is something that's very prevalent in
our society
in our world and you know in our
community of entertainment
it has been something that
[Music]
is more recently being recognized as
something that people need to
pay attention to and really make drastic
changes
um i don't know that it's going to
shift immediately but i think that
people
are trying to highlight that more
and i'm glad to be in a community
that is aware of that and willing to at
least
acknowledge that things can be better
uh just to wrap things up charlie's
angels is celebrating its 20th
anniversary this year it's one of my
ultimate favorite movies um do you have
like a really fond memory of being on
set with drew and cameron or just
you know a day on set that really stands
out for you
i mean every day was pretty magnificent
we had so many different costume changes
and makeup changes and
wigs and i mean every day it was like
going to a candy store
and doing something crazy whether it was
stunts or being out
you know in the palisades or the ocean
in scuba gear i mean
it was i mean it's funny that time has
flown by i mean 20 years two decades
it seems like we just did it yesterday
you know i remember being at the
griffith park observatory and you know
shooting there with our
wonderful crew and i mean who knew that
it was going to be such a
a big deal to put three women on a
magazine cover
or in a movie that was going to
highlight women i i don't know
you know i don't know how it hadn't been
done before then
and and you know
i don't know that it was that it took
that long
for it to happen and that was 20 years
ago i think we're still making changes
and i think it we still have a little
ways to go